the creepy basement is one of the most
well-established tropes in the horror
genre and it makes sense that scary
movies use basements to frighten the
audience they're confined
dark and only have one exit for escape
we know the threat of basements all too
well which explains why even just
talking about one can
feel ominous not many people have
basements in california
the fact that basements are underground
adds to their creepiness
there's something scary about the
unknown depths of underground spaces in
general
which might explain why nearly every
ancient culture has some belief
in an underworld a supernatural world of
the dead that's below ground and those
stories may seem like old tales that we
don't believe in anymore but their
influence still shows up in modern
filmmaking clarice starling entering a
serial killer's dark basement to rescue
a young girl in the silence of the lambs
sounds a lot like the greek story of the
prophet orpheus entering the treacherous
underworld to rescue eurodice but in our
story telling the use of underground
spaces goes even deeper than that when
explored the underground
actually has a vast collection of
symbolic meanings that you may not have
even noticed so what are the potential
meanings of the underground and how do
filmmakers use them to tell their
stories
it's time to explore what lies beneath
scotty i'm not going down there
okay okay you cowards i'll go
for many characters the underground
represents what they're afraid of in
home alone kevin has that classic fear
of the basement
i've always been afraid of our basement
it's dark there's weird stuff down there
and it smells funny in the film his fear
of the basement symbolizes his inability
to take care of himself after his family
abandoned him but once he faces this
fear
it shows that his character has grown
the confidence to live on his own
characters often confront trauma while
underground in the silence of the lambs
clarice talks about failing to save a
screaming lamb as a child
at the end of the film instead of saving
a literal lamb she has to save a
symbolic lamb a helpless girl held
captive by buffalo bill
for clarice bill's underground lair
represents her lifelong struggle to
silence the lambs that have been
tormenting her so when a character
enters the underground they are in a way
confronting repressed memories hidden
away in their own mind the perfect
example of the underground
representing an individual's own mind is
the character pennywise from it
not only does this evil clown live below
ground but it also morphs into each
character's greatest fear it's a literal
manifestation of their deepest trauma
and in the case of bill
his trauma comes from never coming to
terms with the death of his brother
in all of these films the underground
acts as a space that holds the deepest
most traumatic thoughts in a character's
mind
in the early 20th century psychoanalyst
sigmund freud developed a theory that
called this space in our minds the id
he describes the id as a dark
inaccessible part of our personality
that stores our repressed fears which
sounds a lot like the basements in home
alone and the silence of the lambs
freud's theory had a massive cultural
impact
it completely changed how people thought
about their minds and that new thinking
made its way into filmmaking even though
much of freud's work has become outdated
his theories continued to influence how
we
think about the mind today in classic
freudian fashion the subconscious in
inside out is represented by a dark cave
filled with riley's deep repressed fears
[Music]
the stairs to the basement but treating
underground spaces as only places of
doom and despair would sell them short
in many films the underground does the
exact opposite it lets characters
chillax
hang out in my basement the chill zone
is where we chillax like relax
and chill at once
in real life basements give people a
space to unwind and hang out
safe from the problems of the world
above ground in an attempt to protect
their masculinity men have invented
their own
underground space to shield them from
the above ground pains of dating and
marriage
this is the man cave there's no women
aladdin here in more dramatic films
basements protect people from harm
they can temporarily keep a family safe
from monsters or they can let you make
meth without the cops finding out i'd be
willing to bet that movies actually more
often portray basements as a place of
protection than a place of danger
whether an underground layer protects
your secret identity or an underground
civilization protects you from a robot
invasion the underground creates a space
that hides characters from both literal
and metaphorical danger at the end of
superbad seth and evan retreat to evan's
basement to have a sleepover and they
confess how much they cherish each other
in this scene the underground basement
acts as a place where they can both be
vulnerable and no longer have to act
cool like they do in the rest of the
film the setting calls back to their
lifelong childhood friendship and it's a
comfortable space they will have to let
go of when they go to different colleges
for seth and evan the childhood basement
represents a time they enjoy together
but also a time they have to move on
from as they grow up
many films treat underground spaces as
comfortable but sometimes they can
become
too comfortable a character stuck in a
basement can symbolize someone unable to
handle the real world
meeting with dry bird left bad taste and
mouth
a flabby failure who sits whimpering in
his basement
the classic example of the cushy
underground is the loser who still lives
in his mom's basement
although these days that feels more like
a smart financial decision than the sign
of a loser but to keep the story moving
narrative films almost
always challenge that initial safety of
the underground or they make the safe
underground create a new problem
a bunker may protect characters from the
dangers of the outside world but they
don't protect them from the people they
are now stuck with the claustrophobia of
underground spaces often forces people
into conflict with one another in war of
the worlds ray and his daughter find
refuge from alien invaders by hiding out
in a man's basement but when the aliens
break in they are at odds with how to
deal with them
rey wants to keep quiet but the man
wants to fight back i don't think we're
on the same page
ray quickly learns that the biggest
threat to his daughter's safety isn't
the aliens they're hiding from
it's their supposed savior they're stuck
with underground another film that plays
with the uncertain safety of underground
spaces is 10 cloverfield lane which
constantly makes the viewer question
whether or not the bunker is a shelter
from a radioactive atmosphere or if it's
actually a prison cell michelle spends
the movie plotting a way out
then questioning if she even wants to
get out this claustrophobic underground
showcases the tactics of manipulative
relationships it might suck in the
bunker but outside it's even worse
after i saved you and kept you safe
this is how you repay me an underground
space may protect someone from
above-ground catastrophes but it leaves
them much more vulnerable to
interpersonal conflict with the people
they're stuck with
a perfect example of this underground
dynamic is walt and jesse working in the
meth super lab in breaking bad
throughout the early seasons the two
characters have lots of problems to deal
with they have to keep their meth making
lives a secret avoid detection from the
cops and they struggle with the various
challenges of cooking meth in an rv
but once they move their work into the
underground super lab many of those
problems go away the super lab works
well
and gus helps protect them from the
police at the beginning walt and jesse
treat the job like a typical nine to
five this underground space protects
them from the outside world but it also
magnifies the existing social problems
between the two characters compare a
conflict between walt and jesse in the
rv
to a conflict between them in the super
lab in an early episode the rv runs out
of battery in the middle of the boonies
they bicker at each other throughout the
episode but they mainly tried to work
together to keep themselves from dying
of thirst in the fly episode walt
obsesses over killing a fly that has
contaminated the super lab and
throughout the episode jesse sees it as
a waste of time
both situations involve a conflict that
they must solve but the situation feels
completely different
in the rv it's a matter of life or death
and while they may not approach the
problem in the same way
they both understand what's at stake but
in the fly episode the conflict is much
less about the fly itself than it is
about the conflict between jessie and
walt compared to the rv situation the
threat feels inconsequential
the biggest conflict comes not from an
outside force but from within
the two can't even agree on whether
there's a problem and all the setbacks
come from the two
undermining each other like when jesse
cuts off the power there are many
possible interpretations of what the fly
symbolizes in this episode but what's
clear is that the setting creates a
high-pressure claustrophobic environment
that forces us to focus on the
relationship between walt and jesse
because of the isolated space of the
underground super lab the two have the
most revealing personal dialogue in the
entire series
throughout breaking bad some of the most
important and revealing moments occur
in the underground and the show uses the
underground in a variety of ways like
many films the show uses the underground
to keep things safe
the super lab protects walt and jesse
from the dea but there's also walt
hiding his money in his crawl space and
jesse's storing the meth setup in his
basement to avoid detection but there
are more cultural functions of the
underground that you may not have
considered
underground spaces don't just protect
what is precious they also dispose of
what is harmful
for many crime shows the underground is
the perfect way to dispose of a body
in breaking bad won't jesse bring crazy
aid to the basement to dispose of him
while wall talks with him the
underground setting reminds us that
crazy aids life is on the line
the underground can also allow
characters to yield valuable resources
you can literally yield from the earth
by mining for minerals or you can even
find hidden treasure but there are also
less literal ways to yield value in the
underground
in breaking bad gus uses the underground
super lab to extract valuable meth made
by walt and jesse but when people are
involved
extraction almost always means
exploitation in one episode jesse
realizes just how valuable their work in
the super lab has been for gus
alright 96 million
96 to our three that is messed up yo
while walt scolds him for being
ungrateful jesse points out that the
whole deal
is unfair what world do you live in
one where the dudes were actually doing
all the work
and getting fisted as he says this the
camera cuts to a new
extreme high angle shot looking down at
jesse as he rails against the
exploitation of his labor
it's no coincidence that jesse gets
framed from such a powerless angle when
he's feeling ripped off
filmmakers often use perspective to
emphasize control a high angle shot
makes a character look small and
helpless while a low angle shot makes
them look
powerful add in the fact that jesse is
underground and it becomes clear that
the below ground super lab emphasizes
jessie and walt's powerlessness
like the bunker in 10 cloverfield lane
the lab is both a refuge and a prison
their boss surveils them constantly they
work
under threat of bodily harm and at the
end of the day they make a small
fraction of what gus makes
the episode box cutter uses this spatial
hierarchy to visually demonstrate gus's
power over walt and jesse
after re-establishing his authority by
killing his loyal henchmen he leaves the
lab the scene is intentionally shot to
emphasize the spatial relationship
between gus
and his employees he looks down on them
and they look back up at him defeated
and traumatized
get back to work the underground is a
symbol of walt and jesse's status as
part of an
underclass that serves at the whims of
wealthy upper management
after all breaking bad is a show about
class anxiety
walt's financial struggles are core to
the show and jesse struggles with his
inability to be a productive member of
society it's no surprise then that the
show uses the underground so extensively
because it serves as a clear
illustration of a hierarchical and
exploitative world that forces them to
sell their souls to survive and breaking
bad
isn't the only example of a story that
uses the underground to explore class
dynamics
the film parasite starts with a pedestal
shot moving downward to reveal a
semi-underground apartment
the pedestal shot gives subtle cues to
the viewer by moving the camera up or
down it indicates whether a character is
powerful
or powerless i guess that should do it
in the case of parasite the shot
reinforces that this family is part of
the powerless underclass their
semi-underground apartment symbolizes
their low status in the socio-economic
hierarchy the beginning of the film
revolves around to the family trying to
literally rise above their station
even in the very first scene they're
trying to get reliable wifi by holding
their phones up to the ceiling
symbolically showing that their success
lies upward when the sun gets an
opportunity to tutor for a much
wealthier family he makes the trek to
their house
and in each shot he moves upward along
with the pedestal shot the film also
uses high angle and
low angle shots throughout this early
sequence to show power in the beginning
the camera looks down on the poor family
but as they infiltrate the rich home
they gain control of the frame
at times towering over the rich family
both the camera and the above ground
setting
emphasize the changing hierarchy between
the two families but all of that ends
with the discovery of a new underground
space the nuclear bunker
this underground space completely
reverses the trajectory of the story
in the beginning of the film the family
becomes successful by moving upward but
in a cruel twist of fate their upward
plan starts to unravel once they expose
themselves by literally falling downward
again underground space represents the
powerless and the kim family instantly
lose their control the nuclear bunker in
parasite has many symbolic meanings
it does protect what is valuable that's
what nuclear bunkers were made for they
protect people from a potential nuclear
attack
in the film the bunker keeps a man safe
from the loan sharks trying to catch him
but that protection comes at a price and
it eventually drives its inhabitants mad
and while the bunker doesn't yield value
in a literal way like buried treasure or
crystal meth it does yield the big twist
in the story itself
parasite follows the tradition of
countless films that use an underground
space as the climactic moment
or as a major plot twist there are lots
of films with surprise underground
spaces that i won't talk about to avoid
spoiling them which goes to show just
how important those spaces are for many
stories
what makes parasite such an incredible
example of the underground
is in how many ways it uses it to tell
its story parasite uses the underground
not only to emphasize hierarchy and
exploitation but to show how the stench
of the underground never really leaves
people who manage to climb their way up
you can see all these ideas of the
underground in the very last shot of the
film
after the sun vows to get rich and save
his father from the bunker we get the
same pedestal shot from the beginning no
matter how hard he tries or how much he
plans he remains trapped underground
the underground isn't just a physical
space in this film it's a social
boundary policed by the norms and
manners of an upper-class society with
no interest in admitting anyone new
in parasite there is no meritocracy the
hatch of the underground is locked and
sealed
basements aren't just scary because
they're cold and dark they're scary
because of their power as a storytelling
device
in film and tv the underground
represents a new unexplored space that
may be a source of safety
danger or reward this unknown creates
dramatic tension because
it's so unknown when we see a basement
we're introduced to a completely new
space and we have no idea what's going
to be down there waiting for us
in a way almost every underground space
in film and tv yields something valuable
they yield the most valuable part of the
story so the next time you see a
basement in a film
don't forget to consider how deep it
really goes
like most now you see it videos this one
only contains a fraction of all the
thoughts and ideas we had around this
topic but we want to let you in on the
deeper conversations we had about the
underground breaking bad
and parasite we do that and more in our
latest episode of the now you hear it
podcast
the now you hear it podcast goes in
depth on each month's topic expands our
thoughts and discusses related topics
that didn't make it into the video
you can get exclusive access to our past
two episodes plus our brand new episode
on the underground by going to
patreon.com now you see it and becoming
a five dollar tier member and if you
want to check out our first
episode for free the link is in the
description getting access to now you
hear it is the perfect way to support
the channel while also getting exclusive
long form content so hit the subscribe
button head to our patreon and thanks
for watching
[Music]
you